I'm very struck by the title know my
name why did you want us to know your
name it's such a declaration to me
mm-hmm I'm here to finally exist as my
full self for five years I've had to
compartmentalize my life and it's begun
to feel really fragmented so this is the
first time where I can exist openly and
speak openly and not have to hide a
single element of my life in the very
beginning you didn't even know what
happened to you that's what I find so
hard to believe you're at the party and
you're you admit that you passed out you
wake up and you're in the hospital your
panties are gone you're wearing
different pants but you don't know what
happened to you yes so it wasn't a
matter of saying to the nursing staff or
the doctors what happened here yeah
where are my panties how did I get here
yeah did you ask any of those questions
I think a part of me knew that something
was wrong and I think that's the case
for many survivors it's a feeling before
it has language and it's an extremely
disturbing feeling and you're not ready
to accept the reality of having your
life changed suddenly there's something
you have to attend to there's something
you have to grieve you're gonna take
years to heal you can't accept that in a
single moment you want to believe that
your life will continue as it was and I
think many people it's almost like they
don't think we have lives before this
it's like we have dreams and goals and
suddenly you're derailed why should we
stop everything we're doing to pursue
this case to go after him we deserve our
lives back we deserve ordinary lives we
deserve to pursue careers and schooling
and to take care of our families so why
should we stop everything to deal with
this how can you accept your new reality
in a single morning how did that affect
your life and does it still affect your
life it still affects my life all the
questions I received in court I can
still hear in my mind anytime I have a
drink or go out with friends or
somewhere alone I feel like if anything
ever happens to me when I'm by myself I
will not be believed you need witnesses
you need to be able to explain and
justify and defend every single thing
you do and where those were the ideas
that were put into my head during court
and something normal people might
overlook I think well all these my new
details hold an immense amount of
significance in that context and that's
terrifying you said that you felt that
you were a victim in the court yes again
yes I mean I felt also like a criminal
in court the way they talked to you the
way they attack your character you feel
puncture do you feel picked apart and
every time I would leave I would feel
just completely hollowed out it all I
could do was sleep and not speak but I
was completely despondent for weeks the
recovery was an insane process how
difficult was it for you to decide you
know I want people to know my name I
want people to know what truly happened
to me that day and is continuing to
happen to me I think it was really
important for me to be able to finally
figure out a way to share my full story
because in court whenever you're
speaking you're constantly interrupted
with objections I felt like I could
never speak a full sentence and it was
really important to me to create the
space I needed to write and in writing
like I can write endlessly nobody can
interrupt me and I get to have the
defense attorney be my character I get
to decide when he speaks and when he's
moved aside but all of that is within my
power and it's my narrative there are
many heroes in this story I have to say
from the detective to the district
attorney to your friends and your family
but two of the heroes that stand out to
me are the two Swedish grad students who
happened to be riding their bikes that
night and happened to see you lying
behind the dumpster and they intervene
you said these two guys really change
the trajectory of your life absolutely I
mean
saved me they saw what was happening
they immediately knew what was wrong and
took action without thinking twice
they literally both sat on him pinning
him to the ground and refused to get up
until they knew that I was okay they
needed to know that someone was going to
take care of me before they let him go
anywhere when the verdict came in you
would think you would think that would
be okay I won yeah and now I can move on
with my life but that is not what
happened to you
will you win and then suddenly you're
back in the present and you look around
you realize I don't have a job I don't
have anywhere to live my sister feels
broken my parents your sister died yeah
you look around and everything has been
wrecked you don't even know how to begin
rebuilding your life integrating
yourself back into daily life you fight
so hard just to survive it and emerge
but when you get there it's you feel
empty what did you want us to get out of
the victim impact statement I hope you
heard in it that there was self-love
that there's a lot of power in anger
anger is usually dissing courage we want
to tame the victim and have her be
composed when really for me it was
wonderful I was depressed for so long
when I finally felt anger it was a sign
that I was stepping on my own side and
ready to fight for myself because you
write in the books you know that people
want victims to be inspiring yeah this
has happened to you yes you can talk
about it now let's move on and you get
it life is not that neat yeah oh yeah
it's so damn hard I don't know how
anyone gets through it like this all the
time it's okay to have panic attacks
it's okay to lash out and have periods
of depression all of that is very normal
given these circumstances I wanted to
normalize all the phases that
we'll go through and not feel like
you're behind or you're being dramatic
like you're gonna go through emotional
extremes and of course you are you said
at one point you know I didn't want to
be damaged goods you know what I wanted
yes yeah I thought if anyone ever knew
that I was this body behind the dumpster
they would think I was just dirty or
irresponsible or reckless that I wasn't
capable of hand handling myself and that
I should just be embarrassed wouldn't
really I've learned that I'm extremely
brave for asserting myself I feel more
confident I feel capable I feel like
anything I encounter in the future I now
have the tools to handle them I also
know that I have language have the
ability to articulate everything that I
experience in order to connect with
people I'm very proud of that and people
have taught me that those are my gifts
and so I will continue to share them and
I'm curious about your advice for women
who have been assaulted who are
listening to you right now who we're
trying to think what to do how to do
what do you want women to know about
this process what you went through I
think it's an extremely brutal process
and we need to do more to fix it and
make all of these obstacles transparent
know that if you haven't reported you
don't have to carry that burden of oh I
should have done more I should have said
more the system was not set up for you
to succeed it's not a nourishing
environment it will really hurt you of
course I understand why you'd want to
preserve yourself and you should be
doing whatever you need to do to heal we
need to be working harder to create an
environment where survivors feel
comfortable being supported and knowing
that when they do some form of justice
can be attained they won't just be
completely demoralized and dehumanized
for an extended period of time have you
met the two Swedish grad students who
saved you yes can you tell us about that
meeting yeah well in 60 minutes ask them
what it felt like to meet me
they said it was like meeting family and
I really felt the same there was
something really healing knowing that
they were there from the very beginning
not only at the assault but they
returned again and again to testify at
the hearing and the trial they continued
to show up for me they saw it through
the very end they always wondered how I
was doing and just knowing that there
are people in the world who are rooting
for me that wanted me to be okay help me
get through those moments where I was
most isolated and most afraid now you
have a huge microscope on on you yeah
and you're being applauded and I think
you will really be an example for other
women we're afraid to speak up who don't
know what to do yeah who blame
themselves yeah you know to hear
somebody say so concretely that okay I
was drunk but that is not okay what you
did we all know that yeah
but many women or some women in their in
your position would have said well I did
kind of bring it on myself maybe I
shouldn't have gone to the party yeah
maybe I shouldn't have had that much to
drink yeah but exactly that you can say
I can say I shouldn't have had that much
to drink it's true boom done fixed right
but this problem of violence that's so
pervasive is still not fixed that we're
still allowing to happen fixating on
alcohol to me is so easy it's such an
easily excusable thing that we do to
blame the victim and it's so outdated
and I'm so sick of it there's violence
everywhere it's not just during these
parties it's when you're walking down
the street it's in the workplace it's in
the strawberry fields and you want me to
believe that oh it's the drunk victims
who are bringing it on themselves drunk
or not this is what we endure as women
we do the labor of putting up with this
stuff every day of our lives
we spend our own energy trying to
navigate our life try not to get
assaulted trying to be safe and I'm
tired of fixing who I have to be in
hiding in order to make it through the
day
I'm not going to work this hard all the
time just to keep myself safe we deserve
to live we deserve to go out and have a
drink with our friends and walk down the
street at night we deserve to have a
full life and nobody is allowed to hurt
you period that is the baseline and I
will not make excuses around that
sentence we have to know that sentence
nobody is allowed to hurt you period
no Miller what's been the reaction from
the 60 minutes piece really wonderful I
I just like every night I go to sleep
saying thank you
like I just I feel this immense
gratitude like I began in such an
isolated and terrified place and I
really I didn't enjoy facing the world
in the morning and now like I feel
excited when I get up and I feel excited
when I show up and I get to meet all
these people it's like it's so enjoyable
for me and like such a gift to be able
to experience something like this in my
little lifetime I've come out at the
other end of that spectrum of emotion
and I know it's gonna be difficult and I
know there's gonna be challenges that
are going to come but at the moment I
just feel this immense Welling of
gratitude